let's talk about the SE yakum trade
what' you make of it I liked it for him
but a player of his caliber you know he
he's what I consider a great other a
Horus Grant Robert or I would I would
have liked to see him go to Philadelphia
Philadelphia is is probably one one
piece away and you know as well as Joel
and beid is playing to have a guy like
that next to him almost guaranteed
Championship however Indiana yes however
going to Indiana young team capable if
the chips flow the right way you know U
Trey H bird you know play the way he
playing in the guy Play Tyrese I keep
saying if they continue to play the way
they playing they have a chance you know
but they but they're one of those young
things have to go right like they steal
a game or somebody gets hurt they have
the capability but this guy right here
again he's he is a great other you know
I know they talk about Kawai you know it
was it was um he was reason they won in
Toronto but you can never forget this
guy he he is a important other NBA
Allstar plays great I'm happy for him
but I still think Indiana's one or two
players away but I wish him will 226 and
five he averages shoots better than 50%
plays both ends of the floor been an
All-Star a couple of times been all NBA
second and third team too so uh exactly
what does this do Indiana wise short
term um he fits in they play uptempo
style they're going to run the
basketball they're going to you know
they need versatile players m multiple
guys handle the ball with
Halbert uh you know lot of different
versatility things 225 and six that
that's that's pretty impressive because
Toronto doesn't play at the pace that
Indiana plays so he his numbers prop on
the on the assistance and the rebounding
will go up um perfect compliment long
term I believe he this is last year of
his contract it is and he's making about
30 million a year now it's going to Wi a
bigger deal coming in because now you're
saying I'm the second piece to year
possibilities and the question is is he
because when they won the championship
we saw that he wasn't the second best
player on that team then he was coming
into his own it was when when uh kawhai
left that he became a focal point so
we'll see if he can be a focal point of
a team because halberton gets the gets
rid of the ball now you have to have a
guy who can kind of get offensive things
I think he's an elevated Chris middle
like an elevated version of Chris
Middleton well he was the second best
player when they won a championship you
go look at the
numbers this ain't a good trade for the
Pacers it's a great trade okay it's a
great trade not even a good
trade I love what they're doing in
Indiana they're like hey you know what
let's go for it you only afraid of the
Boston Celtics you're not afraid of the
Bucks we own the Bucks we beat them
pretty much every time we played them
this year the Sixers I think they need
another piece we only got to beat the
Boston Celtics if we got a chance to get
an Allstar an Allstar you don't very
seldom get a chance to get all stars on
your team and you say to
yourself I love you know his numbers
only going to get better cuz he playing
with better players so you see them
moving from seven to where I think they
could get to two or three because listen
the Bucks the Bucks are not playing well
you know act like to say they're 28 and
13 but they're not playing well you know
they gave up 140 points the other night
Dame hit the
shot you can't give up 140 points and
win in the NBA I love what the Pacers
are doing my Sixers I think they need
another player I really do but I love
this trade I know they're going to miss
Bruce Brown I'm a big Bruce Brown fan I
actually think Bruce Brown gonna get
traded again to a contender because he's
such a terrific player but I love what
the Pacers did I think this is a great
trade for them because listen when I
look at this when I'm looking at the
standing I says the Celtics are the team
to beat but we don't fear anybody we
already if I'm the Pacers we already own
Milwaukee the Sixers in the regular
season yeah that but that's that but
Ernie there's it's a bad matchup because
the patri excuse me the Bucks can't
guard anybody they can't guard anybody
and Indi we'll see if Indiana
defensively improves with a guy like
with his Le because you talking about
teams that don't guard anybody I
understand that but Kenny talks about it
all the time they don't guard anybody
but they're saying hey you know what
let's just outscore people they got
better yeah offensively I don't they may
be better defensively but they got
better and like I say the only team you
fear in the East is the Celtics because
they were already number one offensively
um now what are the Chicago Bulls going
to do uh before the trade deadline
because you keep hearing Zack LaVine
here some Demar de rozan possibly well
one of the reasons I admire m jery one
thing I hate about the
NBA is why am I paying bad players for
us to be
mediocre they got some good players
they're not relevant why am I paying
these guys msiri Pro to me with Sam
presty like no we got to get rid of
these guys you got to start to rebuild
at some point you can't say well I want
this this this this they're not going to
give you that because those players
aren't worth their trade pick so if I'm
if I'm the Bulls I'm like Hey we're open
for business let's start the rebuild
well okay go ahead sh I I just I just
hope they trade Zack LaVine to a
contender uh you know he had he had a
stretch there he was looking really good
especially when Alonzo ball was there
but no Lonzo ball and you know it has to
be hard for a player when you hear your
name trading room was like I was traded
five time but I didn't know I just got
traded during the midd night but you
hear all year I'm getting traded I'm
getting traded I'm getting traded he
should probably just go in there and say
hey I'm not going to play until you
trade me since you want to trade me but
you know they're rebuilding they're you
know resetting but you know the type of
player he is I think if you trade him to
a contender he can definitely help
because when he was on his game you know
we talked about him a lot they started 5
and 14 they've gone 14-9 since they are
number nine in the East right now Kenny
what you make of the Bulls well there's
a big difference between the Bulls and
Toronto Raptors though the Toronto
Raptors said we're going to build a
round Scotty Barnes if you're trading
Zack LaVine or you're trading the mo who
are you building around so that there's
a big difference from what Messiah had
done said you know what Pascal cakam has
the ball too much for Scotty bonds to
develop into the player that we want him
to be you know van fleet has the ball
too much for for Scotty bonds to develop
who are we developing into that player
that we're going to build around so when
we make a trade we have to get the guy
we're building around them and typically
those guys aren't available the power uh
Bank caros of the world the Scotty bonds
of the world they're not available
because they're already being build
around so that's going to be a tough
call for Chicago because they don't have
a piece to build a round unless not a
tough call it's not a tough just burn
down the house and start over well you
mean serious over you know like they're
not relevant they're not seriously
they're not I like I I never understand
like you know what I'm not gonna be in
the play in game I need draft picks I
love what MSI did listen give me some
young guys I don't like paying guys 30
40 $50 million year for us to be
mediocre